what's going on guys this is Rob and
this is one of the coolest stories that
Marvel has done regarding Thanos in
years and in fact they give him what is
a new origin here but they also build on
the idea of the original Infinity
Gauntlet story which is just absolutely
phenomenal so one of the things been
going on with Thanos here in Marvel
Comics for those of you all who are
either new here or haven't been
following along is that Thanos has been
dead for a little while he basically
came back to a degree during Kieran
gillen's eternals run but it was him
trying to regain his original body in
power ultimately he was defeated at the
end of that run and he's been gone ever
since but the other part of this
equation is that Thor having replaced
Odin as the all-father of Asgard has
been having these visions of basically
Thanos showing up and leading an army of
dead Avengers right like Marvel Zombies
is what it looks like but leading an
army of dead Avengers against any number
of whatever those forces happen to be
while also wielding mjolnir with the
Infinity Stones attached to it and on
his other hand he has an infinity stone
that we've never seen before and so
while these Visions have plagued Thor
for a while now he travels to Titan in
order to gain a better understanding of
whether or not Thanos is alive if
there's any evidence or any clues as to
what he's been doing to try to attain
this level of power anything that can
point him into the direction of
understanding what in the world is going
on now the crazy thing about this is
that when he gets there he ends up
encountering mistress death and one of
the things she says is that she actually
lingers in this place more than she
lingers anywhere else now this is
building on the old Thanos Rising
storyline which was the first real
origin at least a comprehensive origin
that we got for Thanos in Marvel Comics
The long and short of that origin story
is that Thanos had actually been
manipulated by mistress death ever since
he was a little kid and ultimately she
kind of led him down the path of him
becoming who he is that's going to
change over the course of this story but
the other thing that Thor does as he
makes his way through here Izzy
discovers what is quite literally a
giant filing cabinet along with a room
full of different artifacts now all
these things had been collected over the
years by the father of Thanos who had
basically chronicled thanos's actions
after Thanos initially left Titan and
went out on his own having just done all
these horrible and terrible things but
one of the things Thanos had done was
come back to Titan and actually provide
a sort of Memoir of his own histories
and the things that he had achieved and
accomplished over the course of his life
now a lot of those things aren't
necessarily documented here one of the
cool things we get is kind of an early
prototype of The Infinity Gauntlet
basically a makeshift glove that's
basically sewn together and that could
have been used for it of course Thanos
went with something with a little more
Posh a little more polished when he had
the original Infinity Gauntlet story but
what it does is it jumps to the first
time that Thanos appeared in Marvel with
Iron Man issue number 55. now one of the
things to know is that with thanos's
first appearance it was not the truth
Thanos it was actually a robotic version
of Thanos it was kind of a test by
Marvel to see whether or not there was
any interest in a character like that
when fans immediately loved it Marvel
ended up revealing or introducing the
real Thanos that was accompanied by
mistress death so at the point this
story is being written Iron Man has
encountered the robot Thanos and is just
trying to figure out how to turn it on
because the truth is as intelligent as
Iron Man is Thanos is just that much
smarter one because he's just been
around that much longer and two because
his experience with Technologies and
things like that is far more wide and
reaching than Iron Man's is one of the
things to remember is that Tony Stark
has spent like 90 percent of his life on
Earth so while he is exceedingly
intelligent his understanding of most
all Technologies in the early days of
his character's publication history were
confined to earth now over the years
Iron Man has left Earth and he's gone
out into space and he's encountered all
kinds of different extraterrestrial
races with the Avengers without the
Avengers with Force works the team that
he had that replaced the Avengers for a
little while or at least the West Coast
Avengers team so it's not knowledge on
alien technology has expanded quite a
bit since the time this story was
written but that's why there's a lot of
frustration here is because Tony Stark's
like I'm a futurist right I am
ridiculously capable with machines I
can't even figure out how to turn this
thing on let alone fully understand it
now this is when we start to invoke the
original Infinity Gauntlet story I know
it sounds weird because this takes place
before Infinity Gauntlet so here's the
thing So eventually Iron Man gets
frustrated and goes to simply just
destroy the machine and that's when it
wakes up and it literally says it would
be a Pity to annihilate such a work of
art and where Tony Stark is like what in
the world are you talking about this
like the the Thanos robot basically
chimes in and arrives with a bit of a
warning and what it says here is that in
the future Thanos is going to attain
absolute power now we know by virtue of
this that this is Thanos attaining The
Infinity Gauntlet and what it says is
that in the far future meaning years and
years and years after Thanos originally
gets The Infinity Gauntlet he rules
everything and so what this story does
and it's one of the coolest things here
what it does is it puts forward the idea
that the Marvel universe as it exists
right now is not actually happening that
what had taken place when Thanos had got
The Infinity Gauntlet is he had just
reworked reality right controlled
reality and that is kind of an illusion
right Avail it is all the Earth
superheroes even us as the reader seeing
a series of events we can call those
events a which is basically everything
that's happened since the original
Infinity Gauntlet story Infinity war and
infinity Crusade and Civil War and House
of them and destination all that kind of
stuff none of that's happened what's
actually going on is circumstance B
where Thanos is just controlling
everything from behind the scenes he
just rules it all and it's literally The
Matrix right that's basically what's
being invoked here and so the result of
this is that he tells Iron Man if you
destroy this robot then the Run for the
rest of Eternity you and every everybody
you know everybody on Earth everyone in
resistance will basically be made to
endure a life of torture that's what's
going to happen right any eternity of
that just endless pain or you can let
this robot continue on and you can do
your thing because in truth Thanos wants
to ensure that the events that transpire
that lead to him getting The Infinity
Gauntlet then it actually happens now in
truth because he has The Infinity
Gauntlet in the future and because he is
controlling all things his the end
result of that is guaranteed this is
really just more for thanos's own
entertainment but again this is simply
just an idea that's put out there Marvel
doesn't explicitly say if that's the
case but just based on this possibility
and based on the fact that it may
actually happen Iron Man chooses not to
destroy the robot and ultimately lets it
continue on and do its thing now from
here it jumps to a different story that
took place in thanos's life which
involves a girl named Corella now this
is a story that may or may not be
controversial to Marvel comic fans and
really even the Thanos fans that what
happens here in kind of an ambiguous set
of events that lead to this happening in
the first place mistress death brings
Thanos to her and says like hey there's
kind of an imbalance out there on the
universe I'm gonna need your unique
perspective basically the build up that
we saw in Marvel the end when Thanos
obtained the heart of the universe and
then wiped out the entirety of the
Multiverse and then reconsolidated it
kind of like resetting everything to a
degree but not really marveling did that
and they said that Marvel the end is no
longer in continuity and it was a wasted
opportunity but what ended up happening
is that to better understand thanos's
perspective mistress death actually
whisks him away and brings him to what
is the realm of the undead right to her
realm proper now here's one of the
things to understand the realm of
mistress death is not an actual it's not
it's not depicted as an absolute place
that it changes based on what Stories
being told in the old Chris Claremont
era it was just a series of pillars and
people were living their lives inside
these pillars right it was just little
things like that right the the depiction
changes from time to time but the
overall gist of this is that when Thanos
asked why did you bring me here the
response of mistress death is to speak
of love when Thanos responds and saying
I love only you she says today but today
has not always been today has it and
that's when we're introduced to Corella
now the funny thing about this is that
as we're being told here karela is a
girl that Thanos knew in his younger
days that this is really her spirit it's
not an actual version of the physical
version of Corella it's mistress death
simply saying I like she's presented
here to you because I want to understand
more about this this woman that you fell
in love with at some point along the
line and so this is when the origin of
Thanos changes when the original story
was done in Thanos Rising what it told
us is that he was basically an outcast
because of his physical appearance that
he was looked down upon by other
eternals the result of this is that
being an outcast and feeling basically
ostracized from society Daniel started
finding companionship when he could
where he could the first and really only
form of companionship he ever found came
in the form of mistress death who
appeared as a little girl and she goeded
him down the path of doing exceedingly
dark things experimenting and so on and
so forth which ultimately set him on the
path of becoming Thanos as we know him
and then even once he learned he had
been manipulated by mistress death he'd
fallen so far down the dark path there
was no way for him to come back and in
fact he fell in love with the idea of
mistress death and had basically been
the version of Thanos that we've known
ever since who's been trying to impress
her right the universal simp and so the
result of this is that this this origin
changes things up what it actually says
here is a lot of him being ostracized by
Society being an outcast that all
remains intact but there was a girl
named Corella that actually took pity on
him and learned to love him and the two
of them fell in love and in fact it's a
very very beautiful story right he says
to find a mate was all but forbidden to
me I had resigned myself to walking my
path alone until Corella arrived and he
says when she looked did me she did not
see the Monster the Deviant she saw the
Spirit within me her voice gentled her
touch soothed me and when I looked in
her eyes I saw not just love but the
possibility of Hope for the first time I
experienced hope can you even imagine at
my insistence for her protection we kept
our love a secret but Secrets have a way
of escaping and over time people began
to learn that Thanos was spending time
with Cruella now the two of them were
basically in a relationship which people
didn't want to see one of the things to
understand here and it's really
interesting the way that it's done when
it came to eternals they were very much
a only people who look like us are
allowed to procreate and the reason why
I say that is because with Thanos
physical appearance and him having a
deviant Gene he was an outcast the idea
behind the eternals and the deviants is
that they had waged war against each
other for years and so in effect Thanos
was a person with the gene that belong
to a rival faction to literally the arch
enemy of the of the eternals themselves
and the result of this is that they
ended up basically running together
running away together literally Thanos
says concerned about the overpopulation
of my world I plan to set out to explore
other worlds to see if I could find a
solution I was to go alone and so they
acted when karela arrived determined to
accompany me I tried to argue but I
could never win not with Corella as I
said she gentled me then just as we were
beyond the last of the great cities out
of range of quick help their actions
bore fruit they sabotaged the ship they
literally destroyed it now here's the
big kicker here right here's one of the
big things that happens here this is one
of those instances when Marvel Comics is
adjusting what it does to fit the Marvel
Cinematic Universe it wasn't always that
way it was the MCU basically borrowing
from the comics now it's the comics
copying the movies so the way this
worked in the original Thanos story
Thanos didn't really care about
overpopulation that was never his thing
that was a plot from Infinity war in
Avengers end game it was wholly unique
to the Marvel Cinematic Universe Thanos
never cared about overpopulation in a
world if anything the fact that a world
was overpopulated was a great thing
because it meant more sacrifices for Mr
stuff that's literally what it was and
so in this instance Thanos having left
uh left Saturn's moon Titan left Eternal
Society was because they had cast him
out of course he swore revenge and then
one day he returned and wiped out
everybody on Titan really everybody
except for his dad and then of course
ultimately ended up destroying him you
know shortly after that but it wasn't
really because of some altruistic
motivation it wasn't really God there's
just too many people and not enough
resources we got to find a way to fix
this what this story does is it
drastically changes the way that we see
him instead of him seeing a guy who was
just some kind of demagogue and and
demigod who was hell-bent on impressing
a cosmic entity and being an ultimate
nihilist instead he's now humanized it's
more of a victim's story when it came to
Thanos because what ended up happening
here is that in order to find help and
because oxygen was basically running out
there was only enough oxygen for one of
them to survive Corella gave her oxygen
to uh to Thanos and then went out into
the Wilderness to try to find Aid and of
course ultimately ended up dying but the
idea behind karela and what she was
trying to teach Thanos here was the
value of Life the meaning of life and
the significance of Life the fact that
she was willing to sacrifice hers to
save Thanos was a hope that Thanos would
use that mindset going forward and try
to make the universe a genuinely better
place of course the opposite happened
instead because mistress death had
intervened and manipulated Thanos
because of the fact that he had
seemingly learned the wrong lesson
Thanos went forward believing that
because this ship was sabotaged by those
who didn't want to see him and karela
together that they are a reflection of
the Universe At Large he's literally a
guy with a broken heart that's really
what it was right it's no longer Thanos
the guy who won to conquer everything
it's Daniel's heart was broken by some
guys who were dicks and now the universe
is going to pay for it and so this
changes everything about Thanos but
that's why I say this is controversial
and that's why this story itself is
controversial because Thanos as a
character has always been the guy where
he literally is just a really really
terrible person who's always been a
terrible guy well not necessarily always
after he was manipulated by mistress
death which again is a kind of
victimization story that goes on there
so all we're doing is just kind of
changing the villains of thanos's own
history from mistress death to a handful
of folks on Titan that's really all it
is but again people become attached to
comic book stories for reasons it makes
sense to nobody but themselves and the
result of this is they go forward
wanting to see that story stay intact
and they don't want things to be changed
sometimes that's a good thing and
sometimes it's a problem with this one
this is really an instance where Marvel
is bringing Thanos closer to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but because of the
fact that this sort of appears out of
left field it looks like Thanos won will
probably return in the MCU which makes
good sense because he's so popular and
two even if he doesn't return his origin
story is going to be explored further in
the eternals 2 film and that this will
be a part of his origin story but Ash
Thor is kind of sifting through all
these files and looking through all
these different things that what Thor
ends up finding is something called the
Blackstone and that ultimately this
black stone is gone and Thor of course
says whoever searched this place got
what they came for and that's when he
realizes his grandfather bore Oden's son
the father of Odin is actually involved
in this in some capacity we don't know
how far reaching it is but at the end of
the day Thor doesn't really get a whole
lot of answers except for this kind of
new mystery that like his grandfather is
somehow involved it does send him on
another path and it kind of keeps this
journey going which of course Marvel
will continue doing likely in the pages
of Thor but it is fun and in fact it
actually does continue in Thor number 29
but it is fun and it is really really
cool so thank you all for watching and I
will catch you all later
peace
[Music]